well uh how about we get into one of the
most dangerous stories for youtube
as it were because uh hey if it's the
news it's in the news and
who am i to judge we have this story
from the daily mail you ready for this
one let's go
pentagon scientists reveal a microchip
that senses coven 19 in your body before
you show
symptoms and a filter that extracts the
virus from your blood
gimme
[Laughter]
i can't believe it when i saw this meme
going around i'm like that's not
real i can't believe that's an actual
story that that is being
i mean i'm surprised that that it hasn't
been you know squashed by
google and in all the other uh 60
minutes yeah it's a 60-minute story
it's a 60-minute story story no
let me read let me let me read a little
bit let me read this
pentagon scientists working inside a
secretive unit set up at the height of
the cold war have created a microchip
to be inserted under the skin which will
detect covet 19 infections
and a revolutionary filter that can
remove the virus from the blood
when attached to a dialysis machine does
it have lights on it does that are they
shooting lights in your vein like trump
said
they're going to put it bleach the team
at darpa
have been working for years on
preventing and ending pandemics
they assess the issues and come up with
ingenious solutions which at times
appears to be more science fiction
be a science fiction novel than working
in a laboratory one of their recent
inventions they told 60 minutes on
sunday night
was a microchip which detects covet
infection
in an individual before it can become an
outbreak the microchip is sure to spark
worries among
some about a government agency
implanting a microchip in a citizen by
by some they mean jesus people there's
some people that are very religious
i'm pretty sure they mean everyone
except these like just i don't know bill
gates is on is like yeah
let's do it i want to chip in everyone
do you remember varichit
this was like 10 years ago i think
vaguely or maybe like 50 vaguely refresh
my memory they're rfid chips they would
implant in your hand
oh yeah and you could wave it by a door
and it had your information
on it and the way it works is that the
signal emitted from the reader
provides enough power for it to bounce
back a signal with information
it's brilliant but when that came out
this is like 2000's people were freaking
out like
this is it this is the mark of the beast
there are already biohackers that have
have done that kind of stuff
though yeah i mean there's people for
like full weird like arduinos like in
their arm
your body rejects that stuff but like
this stuff has been around for a while
where there's been some kind of
microchip and betting and there's been
all the conspiracy theorists
and the funny thing is there's a meme
going around because of i think ryan
reynolds
where he posted a vaccine selfie and he
said upgraded to 5g today
i saw that now now i'm seeing all of my
like i'm seeing some of my friends and a
bunch of memes or people are like
getting 5g reception's great
and i'm like i get it i get it it's a
funny joke but the thing is
we the media was desperately trying to
tell people
even youtube is against the rules
they're not putting microchips there's
no microchips there's no covert
microchip stop
and then it's like okay fine okay we
won't say it's crazy we know it's crazy
and then sunday
60 minutes
it's okay for 60 minutes to do it too
yes
i've this conversation probably got this
this stream defunded
i wouldn't be surprised if we get in
trouble for something like this because
you know what happens
the way youtube videos are moderated
it's typically
some dude in like india or you know
china or mexico and
it's outsourced labor where some of
these people is it really
oh yeah yeah yeah my understanding is
i'll put it that way just in case
because you know
but my understanding is it's outsourced
labor because there's so much content
so you get some person who's watching it
and they don't understand context
first you the robots that do it and the
robots are like i see swears beep boop
boop demonitized
then if it escalates you'll get a review
from like a person
and they're going to be like oh
microchips that's conspiracy theory boop
demonetized not anymore
this happens to me all the time though
check it out so i actually have uh i
actually know people at google but i
have a act i have an actual
like google rep that i have to
constantly message like hey this is
demonetized
there was uh we had two videos on this
show we on this
on this channel where we criticized
ocasio-cortez we got demonetized because
of it
and they said you violated our policy
against being hateful towards an
individual she'll send people to your
house
what aoc yeah that guy there was there
was that a
person that was on twitter that made a
comment critical of aoc and the police
showed up at his fbi show not
really you didn't hear about this yeah i
forgot i don't remember the guy's name
um he was a left-leaning guy and he was
he was he said something critical and he
ended up with uh
with someone at the fbi at his house
about the uh because he was he
criticized aoc so i don't think that it
was aoc
that's first well to be fair the first
story that pops up is actually
they tweeted about some something really
bad
it was like causing harm to something
spicy uh
yeah yeah i i'd say it was spicy so
that's if you google search aoc fbi
something i probably can't repeat on
youtube because it's
spicy let's not go there yeah yeah it
wasn't just a guy saying like aoc you
suck it was a guy who said something
like
go do a thing to this person you know
what i mean interesting you see it you
see the story
somebody was basically calling for harm
against aoc yeah i mean i'm looking look
at that i'm looking at this now
or is that a different because the one i
saw was from a couple months ago no no
this is
yeah this is not the one that i'm that
i'm referring to
um so there is a story where a guy was
being mean to her well anyway
while you look that up i'll just finish
off this point they demonetize these
stories because we were critical of aoc
yes and then i submitted for appeal and
they were confirmed demonetized
so then i had to contact google and like
hey and then it took like a week and
they were like sorry about this
they're monetizing that wasn't against
the rules i'm like we're criticizing a
politician dude
you know like what can we say unsettling
in this case we're talking about
microchips that the pentagon has
announced
yes on 60 minutes 60 minutes cbs is that
cbs
that's cbs are you going to get the
microchip i am not going to get the
microphone i want to know what is a
proprietary software
i will i will get the neodymium magnets
in my fingertips oh i am sold you know
you know about that
no do you know about this biohacking
thing if they if they cut open your
fingertip
yeah and they put like a it's like a
coated
neodymium magnet a small one and then
they sew your fingers up and when it
heals
the the magnet vibrates against
electromagnetic fields
so it gives you electrosense what so you
can actually put your hand on a wall and
feel where the power cables are
because and apparently it it feels
different give me like it's a new sense
you're like whoa i've never felt
something like this oh yeah because what
happens is
the magnet is pulling and pushing
against the nerve from the inside and
vibrating
so you can like feel like the the emf
waves the
electromagnetic waves coming off of
electric electric objects and devices
lydia looks horrifying it's cool the
problem is
your body rejects foreign objects so for
a lot of people
what happens is eventually your fingers
just spit them out yeah they just get
pushed further and further out
so there are some techniques they tried
doing they coat it in a material so that
your body ignores it
some of the early pioneers of this have
had the magnets break in their fingers
and you got to get them removed and
there's like infection risks and your
fingertips are particularly sensitive so
getting them sliced open for the surgery
hey man but uh man i've always thought
that was really cool
now microchips i will get neurolink will
you
know i will i don't know that i'll get
first gen
did you see the monkey playing pong no
dude
amazing and it's at the end of the video
can we go from being very scared about
government playing on microchips
talking about monkeys playing he's
[ __ ] good at it he's doing it with
his mind is it a chimp
it's a macaw yeah i don't trust the
government but
elon daddy elon i tell you what there's
there's a totally different kind of deal
going on with you he's open sourcing the
code and you know
what it's tracking and what it's not
tracking he can open source the code but
i'm still relying on someone else to
tell me because i can't code so like
you could you could be like oh you know
look look you can look at the code it's
like people say oh
you can look at the bitcoin ledger and
see i'm like no you can look at the
bitcoin legend
i can't i can't that that's all german
or
whatever our president speaks english
doesn't speak foreign language he relies
on an interpreter the interpreter may as
well be the president
our president is not speaking
come on man you used to journey to
pressure he speaks elderly english
elon musk's company says this monkey is
playing pong with his mind
this video is lit the monkey
also sorry so i will mention it do you
know what an eeg is
electro encephalocephalograms yeah so
you can actually buy them
they've been around for a long long time
long time but there's consumer grade
ones
i i talked about this before we bought
one where it's a band that goes over
your head and then there's like a bar
that goes onto your forehead
and it can detect two different waves i
guess
and so there's a a reader an eg reader
on the computer
and there was a red and blue line and
they're like bouncing randomly
and it's like focus and concentration or
whatever i don't know what it means
and me and my friend we put this with
the eeg on
and we're like trying to focus and the
lines are just random no matter
what's like horny and hungry yeah yeah
but no no no matter what we do we
couldn't get the lines to move
but then we gave it to his sister and
she put it on and she could move the red
line like she figured out real quick and
like the line would like make the line
go up and then she would look at it and
the line would go up
very hungry very super starving so we
were wondering
if these two outputs could be used to
control a drone
so that you have two controls one is to
make it go up
and down and the other is to make it
rotate so you couldn't fly it around
because you'd need
more sensors but with just that
instead of a red line on the screen the
drone could be going up and down
so i bring that up because that wasn't
invasive
it's a headband you'd put on you can buy
all these things right now
does the monkey really need to get his
brain chipped
to be able to play pong the answer is no
he doesn't he does so that way
eventually you can wear it in your head
and type on your phone without your
fingers
aren't you worried about being turned
into the borg no no
no why do you want the newer link
because i want to i because i think that
that elon musk is right
about the interface that to me that's
really the the
the interesting thing the interface that
we have today with the internet
is limited to most people uh as their
thumbs you know you we
like he said he you used to have a full
keyboard for walking around all the time
that it's gone down to your thumbs if
you can manage to just
interface with the with the with the
phone or whatever in your pocket
without having the slowness of your
thumbs and you can just access the
existing internet
by thinking that's something that i find
extremely intriguing and i think would
be
a very useful uh
useful thing to have in your day-to-day
life i'm not looking to be like oh i
want the internet in my brain or
whatever
having that but having that interface
from from that removes my hands
you know the necessity of having my
hands do the typing
to access the internet internet that i i
think is is interesting don't you want
to download kung fu
like in the matrix i i love the idea i
do
um but i also think that there is
a certain amount of uh of of
well i mean i suppose they could you
know eventually if you could if that is
possible
you could download the the muscle memory
and stuff right you need muscle memory
and you need
the muscle proteins to actually build up
to be able to do half the thing sure so
it's not just about
you know it's funny when people are like
in the matrix he plugs thing in his
brain he downloads kung fu and he can
fight he's like i know kung fu or
whatever
it's like well hold on hold on i can
watch someone do something
and they can explain it to me and then
my brain's like got it and then i'll
fall lower because i'm not flexible
enough and i'm not strong enough i just
started taking jiu-jitsu
about a month ago and there is a
significant learning curve to
i don't even know what i'm supposed to
do like for me if i like right now i'm
basically at a point where if i can pass
guard on someone that i'm
that i'm rolling with and i'm like okay
i feel like i've won i i don't
know what to do so not knowing so but
having the information there
would be cool and knowing okay this is
what i'm looking to do
but the actual executing still would
take some kind of
you know some amount of of
physical work i think bro what if you're
actually like a five foot three morbidly
obese dude plugged into a neural link
right now because you've always your
whole life wanted to be a famous heavy
metal singer
and you're in the game right now well
you know then hopefully
you know he never wakes up at least you
can say you enjoy yourself playing a
video game
not cause you know people talk about you
get the neural link you plug in and
you're like
in skyrim you're you're in world of
warcraft or call of duty or whatever
yeah you know i don't think that i think
with with the with vr headsets and stuff
like that that's not super far away
um sensations like smell that you get
when you know if you're in a pla
the the way things smell in a place are
are
i don't know that we could reproduce
that um but neuralink possibly could
by accessing those those parts of your
brain and then you go ahead and you know
you put on a
vr helmet that for the sound and
and sight i mean you know
that they're actually working on virtual
smell by causing electrical stimulation
in your
ear in your inner ear i tell you those
things that'll that'll be tinder would
would the use tinder use would go way
down if that stuff was real like
right now in like we're in a simulation
in the real world phil you're actually
like some 23 year old just like fat fat
kid and you're like i always wanted to
be a heavy metal singer and you're in
the game
ian's actually like a tech billionaire
who's really smart and clean cut
and he's like i just wanted to be this
like free spirited dmt crazy guy in a
podcast so bad it's like you know it's
just you're like i'm
schooling these dudes well so no like no
what i mean is like i'm
very hypothetical obviously but you know
if it's possible to create
a virtual environment where you get to
experience that game
how you know you're not already in it
yeah i mean i've heard people talk about
the
the idea that it's a simulation and
stuff like that yeah musk talks about it
yeah i mean what if he's trying to break
out of the simulation well then
i want him to i i i truly
think that elon musk is like is a
i think that he's he's a probably a
pretty good dude
who isn't you know isn't like the people
at google
yeah i tweeted i tweeted text the rich
and then all the lefties were like yeah
and then a bunch of conservatives was
like haha very funny tim
and then i tweeted tax the rich but give
all the money to elon musk
and they're like okay now now the left
side have examined him yeah they don't
like him at all just but they don't like
him because he has money and he's
successful and people on the left are
you know yeah i was really annoyed when
he blasted the tesla into space and like
this is so
dumb and i'm like well he needed a
payload he needed a weight and he made
something really cool and inspirational
for young people like that's legit you
know yeah
so i i you know i'm fine with it i don't
like the idea that
you got all these billionaires dumping
money into politics so take it all just
give it to elon musk and let them build
a spaceship to mars
i want to see that you know when when
when people like bernie when someone
like bernie sanders criticizes elon musk
it
really really rubs me the wrong way
because bernie sanders has done nothing
but live off of the of other people's
money his entire life he's produced
nothing of value
uh he wrote a book yeah you're right and
he then he made a million dollars off of
his book
yeah and and he is uh then he
stopped talking about the millionaires
and the billionaires no no no no no no
no no just the billionaires yeah now he
talks
he brought him back though he brought it
back did he really i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry sorry you were right you're
right he's not talking about the
millionaires yeah
yeah it's just the billionaires that
he's got a problem but then he brought
millionaires back recently because if
you write a book
you know then you could maybe make a
million dollars don't you
but me i made a million dollars selling
my book
at a 37 tax rate you know
yeah so it's really funny too i'm kind
of stoked on this the media's collapsed
because there's this big upset uh
everyone's angry about uh substance
sub stack is where writers can charge a
fee
and write articles it's really simple
but now you get this high profile
individuals leaving their main outlets
and just doing sub stacks they're
leaving because the main outlets are
garbage
and they're being restricted and they'll
make money it's like youtube
like i worked for vice i worked for
fusion and people are i loved this i
loved this there was some some like new
york journalists and and
they tweeted at me they tagged me on
this they were like remember remember
tim cast man whatever happened to him
and then someone's like
this was like this is like a year and a
half ago or two years ago and they were
like to go from like this high-profile
six-figure
like you know corporate media job to now
what and someone goes like oh man
his patreon is only bringing a thousand
bucks a month they're like wow that's
sad
and i'm like these people know nothing
about what's going on
they live in this bubble where working
for the machine is like the ideal
and i left and started a youtube channel
and i was like i was on joe rogan and
like doing really well
and i was you know business was
expanding and exploding and that's
better than ever
and these people just live in that
bubble yeah so now these new thoughts
are freaking out
because sub stack has just taken
everything away from them but i'm glad
i'm glad
they're they're in free fall their
ratings are collapsing and i think
what's happening is a lot of people like
to say that these
these media companies get woke and then
go broke
they think vice got woke and then went
broke they think these media
companies decided one day we're going to
be woke oh no our money's gone
some of them went the other way some of
them were going broke
and decided to get woke in desperation
they're like our ratings are dropping
what do we do pander
what we pander to i don't know
progressives at least we'll make we'll
maintain that
what was that tumblr yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you